SOWMYA SUBRAMANIAN:
And today we have
a panel on Engineering
Your Career.
And it's going to be led
by Deepti Srivastava,
a technical program manager
at Google, the Storage Group.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA:
Thank, Sowmya.
Welcome to engineering
your career.
I'm Deepti, and we have a
panel of fantastic women here
who represent various different
career paths and career
choices that you can have with
an engineering degree, some
of which you may not
even know existed.
So since we have a very short
time, let's go right into it.
Let's start with you Shambhavi.
And why don't you tell us about
who you are and what you do.
SHAMBHAVI KADAM: Hi everyone.
My name is Shambhavi.
I've trained as an aerospace
engineering at MIT.
I worked at Boeing
for a couple of years,
where my job was to put
the internet in space.
I installed wi-fi on the space
station and space shuttle.
After that, went
back to MIT because I
didn't like sleeping very much.
Got my MBA and started
a company while I
was there with another brilliant
woman named Kim Gordon.
We were both very into the arts,
so we started a company that
was called Voir, we just
changed our name to Depict.
JAY WONG: Hi everyone,
I'm Jay Wong.
I studied computer
science and design at UNSW
in Sydney, Australia.
I started my own company doing
software building business
enterprise software, and now
I'm a UI design and prototyper
on the Google+ Hangouts team.
ELLIE POWERS: Hi,
I'm Ellie Powers.
I grew up here in the Bay Area.
I did my computer
science degree at MIT.
But I always found people
to be just a little bit more
interesting than technology.
So I was happy to find
a way to bring those two
things together.
I've been a product manager
for about 10 years working here
in the Bay Area in
Paris and London.
I'm currently a product
manager on the Google Play
team working in
the mobile space.
DEE SPEED: Hi, I'm Dee Speed, a
UX design manager and lead here
at Google.
My career started in
a very strange place.
I actually have a bachelor of
science or premedical sciences
in biochemistry and physics
with a double major in art.
I actually began as a medical
and scientific illustrator.
Got out of medicine
and decided I
wanted to teach myself design.
So I'm completely self-taught
from beginning to end,
have worked at companies
like Google, Yahoo, Amazon,
Microsoft.
You name it, I've probably
been there and worked for them.
And this is where I am today.
Nice to meet all of you.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: So we
all know my name by now.
It's Deepti, and I'm
a technical program
manager in Google
infrastructure.
I did my undergrad in
England in computer science
and then did grad school
at Carnegie Mellon
in Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania.
And then when I grew up-- and
born and grew up in India.
So this is the farthest I can
be from home, like, literally.
This is a 24 to 30
hour journey back home.
So yeah, here I am.
And similar to what
Ellie said, I really
like science and technology
and critical thinking,
but I also like people.
And I wanted to find a
way to bridge that gap.
And I also like sort of
translating between technology
and not technology and
business and product and design
and various different things
that you can put together
to make what is a
technical product.
So I find myself in this role
now as a technical program
manager, and it's really fun.
So the way we want to
do this is basically
allow you guys to
ask us questions.
So we have a few volunteers
in the room that have mics,
so if you could raise
your hand when you have
a question for us, we can
try and answer it for you.
There's one in the front.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Rasha.
I moved to the US
four months ago.
And that was right
after I decided
to change my career
path from social media
strategies and event planning
to actually programming.
And I got into that,
and I participated
in a contest was like
between Udacity and Google.
That was awesome, and
I developed this game.
And I won for the
most innovative game.
And it was like, oh my God,
I'm doing amazing things.
Then I had this bad idea
of applying for jobs.
And the first job I
applied for was for Google,
and it was the worst
experience of my life.
I'm sorry, no
offense for Google,
but that was my first
job interview ever.
I didn't know what to expect.
And I wanted to do front
end based of what I did
and what I loved.
I didn't know what to
say or do, and I ended up
saying I'm too stupid
to be in Silicon Valley.
That's it.
That must be the problem.
And I cried myself out.
It took an hour, then I was
back to programming and reading
again.
Ever since I came
to Silicon Valley,
I have no life whatsoever, no
friends, I just do programming.
And I even have a study buddy
where I do algorithms for fun.
So I know I want
to do with this.
After this Google
experience, I actually
managed within the last two
months I built two websites,
I'm a mentor at Technovation.
I got someone to
sponsor me, to offer me
a sponsorship for Hack Pride.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Sure.
AUDIENCE: But I still
feel I'm nowhere.
And I don't know
where to go, and I
don't know what-- I might have
applied for the wrong job.
How do I know that I'm
applying for the right one?
I know what I'd
like, but I don't
know what title is fit for that.
So what should I do?
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Let's
start with it's not easy.
Yeah, sure.
So I think the
question really is,
how you do you find the right
fit, find the right job, right.
And we can throw
it to the panel.
But I think, first
of all, it's not
easy for anyone or most people.
So you're not alone.
And the second thing
is, don't give up.
It's not about you and
that you don't fit.
If you are passionate about
something, it'll come out.
You'll find the right fit.
So you have to keep trying.
But I was wondering if
any of the panelists
had a similar experience
and if you can talk to it.
ELLIE POWERS: I can.
One time, when I was looking for
a job, I applied to 250 jobs.
And then I found a job.
I was actually in a
slightly similar situation,
moving from one country where I
was not from to another country
where I was not from,
having no connections,
not even knowing what
job websites to go on.
I know that that can be
incredibly stressful.
It sounds like you're a
really passionate person.
But the great thing about
jobs, you only need one.
Only one of them
has to come through.
Or, even better yet, none
of them will come through.
You'll start your own thing.
It'll turn out to be
awesome, and you'll
be interviewing other people.
So I guess I would just say,
your experience is not alone.
It doesn't mean you're
doing the wrong things.
And try doing some
interviews like fake ones,
or apply for jobs that
you really don't want.
I actually did this
when I was a student.
I signed up.
I knew that there were going
to be some interviews I really
wanted to get through,
and there were other ones
that I would just stick
my resume to saying,
I definitely don't
want to work there,
but I just want to see
what this is all about.
And so maybe finding if you're
already doing mentoring,
maybe there's someone who
can fake interview you.
Or you can go to an interview
for something just as practice.
Because I think it
can be really hard
when you're very
tied to the outcome,
and then it's super
disappointing.
But the first time you try to
do a cartwheel or something
like that, it's
not going to work.
The first time you go to a
job interview, not getting it
I think is like
par for the course.
So just know that you
have to apply to 250 jobs.
So you've done one.
So that means you have 249 left.
So just check them off.
And if you get a
job before that,
you're doing really awesome.
AUDIENCE: How do
you know you applied
for the right type of jobs?
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: So--
JAY WONG: I guess you
can go ahead, Dee.
I'm sorry.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA:
Oh, Jay, sorry.
Yeah, I was just thinking that
to Ellie's point right there,
now there are so many
resources out there.
You can go online,
you can look up
what the interview
questions are,
you can look up what people
think about jobs, like what
type of job they applied
for, what the outcome was,
what it that was missing
in their resume, what
was it that was missing
in their questions.
Practice for anything
is important.
And as Ellie said,
you have to start
with the ones you
don't care about.
The other thing
about job interviews
is we're all really stressed
out about getting a job.
But the point of
the job interview
is not just you
being interviewed,
but you also figuring out
if the people you're talking
are the people you
want to work with.
What is the kind of
work you're doing?
So that you understand what
the job role really means
and whether it's a
fit for you or not.
That's how you figure out if
you're-- the title is almost
immaterial in some sense.
Let's say there's a title
VP of blah blah blah.
The point is, what does it mean
for you to work at that job?
What are they
expecting from you?
And do you want to be
doing those things?
Like if you got an interview
with Google or Facebook
or whoever, and you went there
and the job that they described
that you had to do, you
didn't like, it's OK.
It's OK to say no.
It's OK to be like, this
is not the right fit,
maybe I should try
something else.
So it's a matter
of trial and error
and also educating
yourself beforehand.
SHAMBHAVI KADAM: Jay,
were you saying something?
JAY WONG: And also, the role
that you're being hired for,
you can kind of
make it your own.
Even though I was hired as
a user interfaces designer,
I also have a computer
science background.
And I found that I
really missed doing
a lot of engineering stuff.
So I kind of have moved into
more of a prototyping role.
And that's not necessarily on
my title still, but day to day,
I'm doing a lot of technical
building things, building apps,
and I guess that you can
kind of make your career
or make your job role
be whatever it is.
And you don't have
to just think,
I'm being hired for
this role and this
is the only thing I'm ever
going to be able to do.
Just know you can kind
of move and create
your own career path.
SHAMBHAVI KADAM: Do we
have another question?
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA:
Thank you for that.
AUDIENCE: Say you want
to switch into a role
that you have no experience in.
For example, you want
to do machine learning
and you complete a machine
learning course on Coursera,
but every time you apply
for that particular job
in every company
they're like, you
don't have experience
so we'll not hire you.
What's your advice on that?
DEE SPEED: It only takes
one hiring manager somewhere
along the line to
believe in you.
So first of all, don't
stop and give up.
If I had done that,
I would not be here.
I drew pictures of bugs and
cellular matrices of plants.
And yet, to say today that I
lead a design team at Google,
it's a big feat.
Actually, this goes
along with what
you had spoken about as well.
Be careful who you
compare yourself to.
It's very easy, especially
in Silicon Valley,
to get caught up in
this bubble that I
need to be as good as this other
person that I've heard about
or that term rock star,
we had a discussion
about this earlier,
who's being bandied about
so much and so often.
Just really be careful who
you compare yourself to,
and honestly don't give up.
Our industry changes so much.
You take four months
off, four to six months,
and something new is
available yet again.
Just keep at it.
And really, it'll come down
to there's that one hiring
manager that looks at you and
sees that potential and says,
you know what, that's fine.
Because at the end
of the day, why
I would hire you based
on your potential
is you're probably going to be
a more long term, comfortable
employee.
I've invested in you, you feel
comfortable, you've grown here,
you learned a lot.
You're also more likely to
stay than the hotshot guy who's
looking for their next fix.
They're more likely to move
on a lot quickly, right.
So there's a lot to be said
for just sticking to your craft
and being adamant
about it, that that's
the path you want to follow.
SHAMBHAVI KADAM: I'm going to--
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: This
is my exact, sorry,
this is my exact what
happened to me last
14 months ago for a year before
I became a technical program
manager in Google
infrastructure.
That I knew I wanted
this job where
I wanted to lead
a technical team,
I wanted to be part
of the technology,
but I wanted to do more
than just programming, which
is what I had been
doing for a long time.
And the thing is, when
somebody sees your resume
and sees that you have 6
years of systems engineering
experience, that's what
they want to hire your for,
because that's where
you've proven yourself.
But it takes, as Dee said,
it takes one hiring manager.
And it took me a
year to get that job,
because I kept saying this
is-- no, I don't want this,
I want that.
So I'm going to keep on asking
for that job until I find it.
I'm not going to settle.
The one thing you have to be
comfortable with in yourself
is this is really
my passion, this
is really where I
know I will be good,
and if I haven't proven
myself that's fine.
I've proven myself in
these other things.
I'm a good engineer,
I've managed--
you have to highlight
how what you want to do
is something you can
learn on the job for sure.
But you also have to have
the confidence to say,
I want to do this.
This is what I'm going to
do, I'm not going to settle.
So whatever else you
offer me, I don't want.
I want this.
SHAMBHAVI KADAM:
And I want to 100%
agree with everything
that they've said.
At my company, we've
been hiring recently,
and we really look for
that potential in a person,
even if they don't necessarily
have the degree in computer
science or a degree
in what they've done,
we look for your
passion projects.
What are you working
on on the side?
And if you can show
something really
cool and interesting
that you've built,
were very interested
in talking to you.
And I think that's
something that you could do.
Obviously, you have a
passion for building things
and you want to
learn new things.
And if you can show that
person who's interviewing you
that, yeah, I don't
have a degree in this
but I've built something
cool around it,
or I'm very passionate about
it and I do it on the side,
it's going to come out
and it's going to show.
DEE SPEED: If the hiring manager
is very smart and strategic,
they would hire
you, because you're
putting your passion
into your project.
I would rather hire
you than someone
who'd been doing the
same job for 10 years
and they were tired of it.
You're not going to get
the motivation out of them
in the same way that you
would, because you're
more likely to try harder.
SHAMBHAVI KADAM:
Absolutely, you're
looking for fresh energy, like
a new perspective on things.
And I think that's
very, very valuable,
and that's something
you can show people.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: So
maybe after this, we
can get a question on
the back, because I
feel like the peeps over
there are getting neglected,
and we don't want that.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA:
Yeah, absolutely.
AUDIENCE: So see, if you were
working as a senior software
engineer in a small
company and you
got a really good
opportunity in Google
but that position itself
were a junior, right?
So it's like the emotion
in a kind of a title,
whereas it's not that emotion.
Maybe you are working with the
really cool people in Google,
but you have a senior
software engineer
and sometimes people are
like, no, title matters.
How can you overcome that?
And because instead of going
into higher in your career,
you are just climbing
down the hill.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA:
So is the question
that you're getting
a job as a similar--
AUDIENCE: So you are working
as a senior software engineer,
but although you are
trying for senior position,
but you get the software
engineer position.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: I see.
Mm-hmm, OK.
AUDIENCE: Although that
position has more innovation,
but the title itself
takes senior out of it.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Yeah,
so the question really
is what do you do if
you get an opportunity,
but the title isn't
what you're expecting
in terms of career
acceleration or career growth.
So do any of you want to
take it, or shall I go?
SHAMBHAVI KADAM: I
mean, for someone
who works at a small company,
I can tell you that titles 100%
don't matter.
It might be different,
I don't know,
if you're at a bigger company.
But we have people
who we will promote up
if they do a really good job
and prove themselves on the job.
And show them, show
us, that you have
the passion and
the capability, we
will give you the
responsibilities that you need.
But as for titles, I would
never let that slow you down.
You can show people what
you can do on the job,
especially if it's
an opportunity
that you really want.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: So I think
another thing to think about
is that why do you
want that senior title?
What is it giving you?
Is that your peers are
giving you validation?
Is it that you're getting
validation yourself?
Is it that with that title comes
a different compensation layer?
What is it?
So for example,
in my team, people
from level two to level six
are all software engineers.
I mean, and all TPMs are TPMs.
I'm not going to tell
you I'm TPM level x.
What does that tell you?
What does that tell you
about my ability to do X Y Z?
So that is very
important, I think,
especially if you want
to have a 30 year career
and you have a long
term trajectory.
What is it?
Are you tying your
self-worth to your title,
or is the title giving
you something else?
So if you do a good
job-- so first of all,
if you're in a company where
the only thing that matters
is the title and that's the
only reason why people listen
to you, you might want
to think about why
you want to be in that company.
And the second thing
is, the real validation
is when you get responsibility
and when your peers respect you
for your opinion and when
your managers compensate you
in various ways for
being part of that team.
That is the real validation.
There's no point in
being VP and then
getting the same type of
compensation or validation
or [INAUDIBLE] as
somebody who's junior.
So you really have to look at
whether you're tying yourself
to a title, and
whether where you are
is really respecting your input.
DEE SPEED: There are times,
and there will be times,
in your career when it actually
is a very strategic move
to take a step
backwards, or what
may feel like a step backwards.
But you have to
figure out, is it
because I'm gaining something
for myself out of it?
Are you learning new
skills that otherwise you
wouldn't have done?
Think about it like this.
Can I learn new skills in a
less high profile environment
where there's less stress?
I can focus on that and just get
better at whatever my craft is,
and then this is yet another
tick on my resume of something
great that I've done.
Then you go out and seek
that higher level position.
But by no means please,
please no one in this room
tie yourself to a title,
because titles come and go.
They change every day.
I mean, ask any UX
person how many times
we've gone through title
changes, even the last month.
One day you're a
designer, the next day
you have no clue what you are.
And you still can't
explain it to your parents
when you go home
for the holidays.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Did you
want to add something, Jay?
JAY WONG: Yeah, and
just as a real world
kind of example of
what Dee was saying.
So I founded my own
company, and I was CEO,
and now I'm a UI designer,
one person in a very, very
large company.
But the reason why I
did that is because I
wanted to surround myself with
a lot of really amazing people,
and I wanted to learn from them.
And at Google,
you're not just going
to come straight in as a
senior software engineer.
It's about proving yourself.
And people at level
three or four or five,
we actually all do very similar
jobs at different levels.
You're doing the same thing.
And a lot of the time,
all the level really
is just an indication of
what contribution you've made
and how you've
proved yourself to be
more valuable to the company.
And so the title
is very trivial.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: I think
I just want to summarize,
because we've got some
really great points.
If you're learning, taking
a step back is a good thing.
If you're just
sitting there because
and you're not learning,
you need to move.
So do we have a
question in the back?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, hi.
Dee Speed, I have
a question for you.
As you mentioned that a
strategic manager would surely
consider someone who wants
to make a role change,
like from an analyst
to product manager.
What is the best
approach to even make
a contact with that
strategic manager?
Sometimes, some of our
resumes get filtered
at the recruiter level.
Could be it will
be your best match
or you'll have great ideas.
How is the best way
to develop a network,
or how can we reach out
to that right manager who
would even look at your resume?
DEE SPEED: So your
question is how
can you-- what's the best way
to reach out to someone already
possibly in the role that
you're looking to move to?
Is that when you're asking?
AUDIENCE: Or in the
role that will be more
of an informative
section that you
can have an informative
interviews most of them already
for.
It's more of a job that your
typical manager would have.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA:
So you were saying
that there's a good manager will
seek you out and actually hire
you or at least understand
that you have potential.
DEE SPEED: Definitely make
yourself feel known first.
Approach that manager
and explain to them.
I've actually added
two people to my team
recently who had very
little background in design.
But what they did have that
I found our team was lacking
was really good skills in
observation and analysis.
And considering our work
on Google Analytics, which
is a measurement
tool and a product,
there were skills that
they brought to the team
that I hadn't otherwise
really thought
about until they brought it up.
So for sure, definitely
seek out those managers.
Like I said, if
they're a good manager,
they will sit down with
you and take the time
to try to understand
your skills set.
And don't be afraid
to talk about yourself
and sell yourself up.
It's really difficult
for a lot of us to do.
I still find it difficult
for myself come time to say,
should I go up for
promotion or should I not.
There's a lot of that.
So again, if you feel
you're lacking a skill set
that's one thing, but don't
be afraid to chase it and talk
to those people.
Talk to also the people that are
in the level that you think you
may be arriving to
that position in.
So say you're coming
from sales and you
do want to go into
something like design.
Talk to a designer who just got
hired, because they're probably
on that same entry
level path as you.
Talk to them about
their career history
and the basic
requirements or the skills
that they've gathered
up until that point.
But really, it's a conversation
that actually just happened.
AUDIENCE: [SNEEZE] Sorry.
JAY WONG: Bless you.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: You
make yourself known.
DEE SPEED: Hired.
ELLIE POWERS: So the way I think
about making career changes is
that usually when
you're making a change,
you're changing something,
but you're probably
pivoting and keeping
other things the same.
So that could be, for
example, maybe I'm
working as a software
engineer on one product
and I'm going to go and become
a tester on the same product.
Or maybe I'm moving from
one company to another,
but I'm keeping
my role the same.
So I think
understanding what are
the things that you
want to keep the same
and what are the
things that you're
willing to do differently
will be helpful.
And I think if you're
trying to, let's say,
I'm a product manager so I'll
just use that as an example.
If you're an analyst
now and you want
to become a product
manager, is there
some background that you have
as an analyst that would now
actually make you a very
attractive product manager?
So, for example,
what Dee was saying,
if you have the
skills of observation
or you're a good
analytical background,
maybe you'd make a
great product manager
on an analytical
product, or a product
that you used to
be a customer for.
If I send a lot of Gmails,
even if I don't know anything
about being a product
manager, maybe I
have opinions on how
Gmail should work.
So trying to create a case
both in your mind and the mind
of the hiring manager
about well, look,
I realize that a few things
are going to be a little bit
different, but actually
here are the things
that I can use to transfer
my previous experience,
whether that's an industry, a
company, a product or so on.
And then also find ways to start
doing your new job already.
And that could be taking
on a separate project,
like being the product
manager for a side project
that you're doing, or for
a charity, or one thing
we do at Google is these
20% percent projects.
So going and helping
another team.
I've had a lot of
people approach me
and say, well I've essentially
taken on a new project
where I'm acting as
the product manager.
So even though
that's not my title,
I actually have
a bunch of people
that I've been acting
as product manager for,
and they could talk to
you about my skills there.
So just focus on how you
can create that continuity
in the mind of the
hiring manager.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: So I just
want to add to what Ellie said
about how you can make it
easier, how many things you
want to change at the
same time while keeping
certain things the same.
Very important.
You could also take
the really hard road
that I took where I changed
my job, my company, my team,
my house, and everything
at the same time.
Not a great idea.
Of course, it builds
character I guess,
but you don't want
to necessarily do
that each time you change.
The other thing is, I
think girls or all of us
think that people
can read our minds.
They can't.
If you see some guy, some
manager, some person, guy,
girl, whatever, and you
want to be in their team
because they seem like
really cool managers
or they're doing
things that you want
to do but you don't know how
to approach them, talk to them.
More often than not--
this is a secret
I learned like now, 10 years
after I started my career--
that people are usually
happy to talk to you.
They actually want
to talk to you.
They're probably getting
away from a meeting
because they're talking to you.
So they want to do that.
So approach them
and don't be afraid.
I mean, OK, so you
sounded silly once.
That refines you to sound
better the next time.
See what sticks,
what doesn't stick.
JAY WONG: Yeah,
and always remember
that it's not just
that's looking for a job.
We're all looking for
great people, too.
So it's in their best
interest to talk to you.
I actually think a really
good technique is just
to reach out to, I
think as Dee said,
reach out to other designers.
And that's not even necessarily
within your company.
Like if you go to
events where there
are people that are doing the
things that you want and you
reach out to them, I'm sure
that any number of them
would be happy to talk to you
and happy to give you advice.
And there are people
always looking.
So I think that technique
works really well.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA:
Yeah, so I think
we're all touching on
networking and fearlessness.
So I think the
next one will have
to be our last
question, because we
have almost three
and a half minutes.
OK, so we have one over there.
Sorry, sorry guys.
AUDIENCE: OK, so
what advice would
you give, if possible
all of you one each,
to somebody who's
basically struggling?
And that's me in this case.
I'm working with a
start up for four years,
and I feel it's a pretty stable
stipend, everything is good.
But moving up in the
ladder is difficult.
So I'm trying to switch and
move to other companies.
I have really good interviews
lined up at big companies.
But I want to move to
a product management
from my engineering role.
But I feel if I go to
some other company,
I'm going to stay
at the same level
or doing the same thing for
the next four or five years.
So what kind of
advice you would give?
Stick here, try to
get the role you want,
or move and maybe
in the new company,
take the risk of moving up to
the other position you wanted.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Sure.
So the question is,
how do you decide
whether you want to stay
in a particular role
after you've been
there for a while,
or do you want to switch
to a different role?
I think what I
suggest is we all just
talk about it really quickly.
So I'll just start and then
we'll end with Shambhavi.
So here's the thing.
You have to think
about where you are at
and how you're feeling about it.
If you've been in a role--
because I was in this situation
also.
I was in a role for
five or six years--
yeah, I've been in
every situation,
haven't I. I was in a
role for the five years
and I was like, if
I just stick it out.
I'm one of those people
that doesn't quit.
Like bulldog, you chew
on it and like, yeah.
That's sometimes a good
thing, sometimes not.
So if people haven't noticed
you and haven't given you
the kind of things you
want in five years,
chances are they're not going
to give it to you anymore.
The second thing is, you have
to be aware of what you want.
So when you're talking
to the next interview
that you're doing, next
roles that you're looking at,
you have to be clear
and confident that this
is what I want, can you
give it to me or not.
If not, why not?
What am I missing?
But you can't settle then,
which is what I said earlier.
So you have to be clear on
what you want and go for it.
Sorry.
Dee.
DEE SPEED: If you are
feeling frustrated,
the frustration has a source.
The frustration could be
anything from I've been here,
I'm not being recognized,
to I'm just bored.
So first recognize
the frustration.
And then I think a
lot of us forget,
when we're interviewing
at companies,
we forget to ask the company
what can you do for me.
So you should be asking
that next company,
if it matters to you that
I'm in an environment where
I can continue to learn, I want
to work around people that yes
are smarter than me and frankly
scare the crap out of me,
they're so brilliant.
That only makes you better, and
don't be afraid to chase that.
But be really clear what your
motivations are, and don't
feel like you're ever stuck.
I mean obviously, if this were
my mom saying this, she'd say,
honey, don't leave that
job just yet until you've
got something else lined up.
And I'd say OK yeah,
that's a smart move.
There's so much work
right now in so many areas
of our industry,
just don't be afraid.
Be completely fearless and
seek out what you want.
Because you don't want to look
back after another two years,
and you're still at
the same company,
and you're only slightly
more miserable wondering
why you didn't take a chance.
Go ahead and take the chance.
ELLIE POWERS: I
guess super quick.
I stayed in my first
job almost five years
and I've never seen another
job that long since then.
It sounds like you
need to shake it up.
I would definitely
encourage you to go
to something that makes
you feel passionate again.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
JAY WONG: Yeah, I
would say always
think about what is
it that you want.
And think about where
you see yourself
or what you want to
be in five years.
And really take a
hard look at do I
think that the company
that I am at right now,
are they really going
to offer me that?
And be really
realistic about that.
And don't be afraid to take the
risk, because the reality is,
always think of the
worst case scenario.
There are so many
people that are looking
right now for people with
our skill set, especially
in this industry.
And the worst case is you can
always just kind of go back
to the job you were
doing before or maybe not
always, but something similar.
And you really don't have that
much to lose but a lot to gain.
SHAMBHAVI KADAM: I would
say start your own company.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Yeah.
No, but I mean, if
you have an idea,
definitely you
should consider that.
But I think what
everyone has said so far
makes a lot of sense.
I went through the same
thing when I was at Boeing.
I was a little bit
bored at my job,
and I really liked
it but I wanted
to pursue something else,
so I just moved to Japan
and started working there.
I think it's always very
important to go and do
something that you're
passionate about.
Life will always give
you great opportunities,
you just have to reach for them.
AUDIENCE: Cool,
thank you so much.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA:
Thank you everyone.